finland's position neighboring the ussr
was not exactly a comfortable one
from the days of its independence
through world war ii and well into the
cold war there were leaders in moscow
who saw finland's addition to the ussr
as inevitable
yet as you know finland remained an
independent state
which raises the question why didn't the
ussr annex it
so finland first came into existence
during the russian revolution
at the end of 1917 as the government in
the russian empire was overthrown by the
bolsheviks finland declared independence
now finland wasn't exactly in a good
place at this point since it was
undergoing a brief civil war between the
communist reds and the non-communist
whites
the whites won and it wasn't long until
some finns wished to expand their new
state at the expense of russia which was
still fighting its own civil war
by 1920 finland and russia signed a
treaty fixing the border at this
and in the following two decades things
remained fairly calm if tense
joseph stalin who was now in charge had
for a long time wished to restore
moscow's control over the former
territories of the russian empire which
obviously included finland which is why
in 1939 after signing the molotov
ribbon-trop pact with germany he sent an
ultimatum to finland
move the border to here or face war
finland
chose war and this war the winter war
was to put it mildly not a great success
for the soviet union
despite this finland wasn't in a
position to fight forever and so it
agreed to hand over these lands to the
ussr and pay some reparations
and it was only a year later that
germany launched its invasion into the
soviet union and the finns jumped on
board looking to claim these lands this
war called the continuation war went
fairly well for finland at first and
they pushed this fire into the ussr
now when germany's advance stalled so
did finland and by 1944 the soviets had
pushed the finns back to here
and in this year the soviets accepted
finnish talks for peace
now they could with enough men and
effort have conquered finland in its
entirety but stalin opted not to
this was because it would have cost a
great deal in terms of lives and
material and they were much needed in
the struggle against germany
there was also a concern that annexing
finland would mean that sweden would
become much more hostile with the ussr
now on its border
in the end finland had to sign a pretty
humiliating treaty
they saw it lose the previous areas that
it had agreed to hand over to the ussr
along with this territory in the north
it also ordered finland to unban its
communist party and place the finnish
leaders from the period of the
continuation war on trial for war crimes
so it won't exactly shock you to find
out that the ussr was not on good terms
with finland when the cold war was at
its beginning
stalin was extremely distrustful of them
and finnish leaders were
frankly terrified that the soviets would
make an attempt at annexing them
some of this stress came to an end in
1948 when the soviets brought them a
proposal
a friendship treasy this did several
things it stipulated that finland was
allowed to remain a free and independent
nation providing it didn't allow anyone
to invade the ussr through it
it also meant that officially finland
was neutral meaning no nato and no
warsaw pact but unofficially it was
expected that finland wouldn't oppose
the ussr in foreign diplomacy
so this policy was known in the west as
finlandization
whereby a small sovereign nation
bordering a superpower does as it's told
to maintain its independence although
cuba didn't get the memo
now for all of its derision the policy
did keep finland independent throughout
the cold war
in the end the ussr never annexed
finland because it didn't need to
it would also have pushed sweden into
the arms of nato and lost them an
agreeable independent voice in world
affairs
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker
anthony beckett
the pastry section danny maloney rob
waterhouse
mo aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley
jerry lamdin marcus asner gustav swann
john bailey
colin castleman rasheed ali spinning
three plates filter oink oink izzy
david silverman maggie paxkowski winston
k wood
spencer lightfoot robert wetzel
fortunate calf lexi schwinn
skye chappelle and marvin cassell